it's taken several stuttering weeks to
develop and validate an accurate
antibody test for covid19
but the government now has 10 million
available
health and care staff patients and
residents will be front of the queue
it's not just about the clinical
advances that these tests can bring
although
obviously that's important it's that
knowing
that you have these antibodies will help
us to understand
more in the future if you are at lower
risk of catching coronavirus
of dying from coronavirus and of
transmitting coronavirus
at the moment swab tests are used to
check whether people currently have the
coronavirus
the new blood test for antibodies will
tell scientists how many people have had
the infection since the start of the
outbreak
came in a box with the instructions the
first thing you see is a warning to say
that you have to follow the instructions
very carefully before you do anything
and then the instructions are very
comprehensive
um yeah telling you how to wash your
hands first make sure you have plenty to
drink
and then the next step is to swab your
finger with the alcohol swab
so make sure it's clean um and then the
dreaded task of removing the safety cap
from the
the lancet and pressing it down into
your finger to get the blood out
private testing is also about to take
off
martin bamford bought a kit from a high
street pharmacy
he'll post a blood sample to a lab he
had a severe sore throat and fatigue in
early february but dismissed it as just
a winter bug
now he's not so sure i think i might be
slightly less cautious slightly less
anxious
if i found out i have had it and i
possibly have immunity to it
but i'm generally quite a cautious
person anyway i don't really leave the
house i follow the government's advice
so
i suspect it won't if i find out i
haven't had it i'll probably become even
more cautious and already slightly more
anxious
the world health organization has warned
that antibody tests whether through the
nhs or
private kits give no guarantee on
immunity
and health and care workers would still
need ppe
i think there's a really strong
curiosity and compulsion that's driving
us to one on a personal level these
tests but what we need to realize is
that
at the moment it doesn't offer any
individual benefit to know whether your
antibody test is positive
because we don't have enough certainty
that a positive antibody test
will definitely protect you from
infection
as more people take the test the better
the data
small studies suggest seventeen percent
of people in london
and a little over five percent in the
rest of the country have had the virus
more wide scale testing will tell
scientists how it's spreading
thomas more sky news